Naruto is one of the most popular
anime franchises of all time.
With over 940 episodes in the Naruto series, and
multiple movies, new fans may feel overwhelmed.
We'll explain the correct order in which to
experience the sprawling Naruto franchise.
"You can do this! Believe it!"
Naruto opens with mischievous Naruto
defacing a Mount Rushmore-esque cliff
portraying the Hidden Leaf Village's elders. At
the time, he's a goofy troublemaker, friendless,
and pathetically unskilled. Unsurprisingly, he's
mocked by his classmates, especially his crush
Sakura, who's in love with the ultra-cool Sasuke.
But soon enough, things turn around for Naruto.
He becomes a shinobi, gets on a team with Sakura
and Sasuke taught by the impressive Kakashi,
rescues Sasuke from a seemingly undefeatable foe,
destroys all expectations in the Chunin Exams,
defeats a tailed beast, and takes on a legendary
ninja as his sensei. Plus, he learns the
Rasengan, one of his most powerful moves.
Since Team Seven is still together in the first
Naruto movie, Ninja Clash in the Land of Snow,
it must take place before Sasuke leaves in
Episode 108. It must also occur before the
mission that begins in Episode 102, which
results in Sasuke's injury. Furthermore,
Naruto has the Rasengan, so it has
to take place after Episode 96.
As Sakura is in Episode 99 and all three are
together in Hidden Leaf Village in Episode 101,
this would be the perfect place for
them to go on their snow mission.
With all that in mind, this movie
is a whole lot of fun. It introduces
some cool Hidden Leaf Village ponchos,
features killer snow-strewn battles,
unveils some of Kakashi's best jutsu, and
culminates in Naruto's multi-colored Rasengan.
This run of Naruto episodes contains one
of the most compelling arcs in the series.
Naruto and his fellow genin — or junior
ninjas — set off to bring Sasuke back,
led by the recently promoted Shikamaru. Each
young shinobi fights high above his level in
this storyline, which also introduces cooperation
with their new allies, the Three Sand Siblings.
Furthermore, the arc ends in Naruto's
first great showdown with Sasuke.
In the Naruto manga, this arc is what ends young
Naruto's story. Most of what follows in the anime
is considered filler. You could skip the next
60 episodes if you're only looking for canon,
but we advise otherwise — why give up on
what ends up being a whole lot of fun?
This is a really unique movie because
it brings Naruto, Sakura, Shikamaru,
and Kankuro together. Also, it includes
heavily armed battleships and soldiers,
neither of which appear in the series proper.
While there aren't signposts in the filler
episodes that might help identify where the
Naruto movies fit after Sasuke's departure,
there are some fan theories about their order.
One says Stone of Gelel takes place after Episode
147 because the movie originally premiered at the
same time as Mizuki Strikes Back. Supporting
this is the fact that Naruto and Shikamaru work
together during this arc — it makes sense, then,
that they continue that cooperation in this film.
Other fans maintain Stone of Gelel occurs after
Episode 160. Ultimately, it's up to you!
This stretch of Naruto contains more fun filler
episodes, though none feature any developments
vital to the central story. Some viewers suggest
powering through the series by skipping Episodes
143 through 219. But if you do so, you'll miss
episodes that showcase characters' deepening bonds
and growing skills. If the whole point of watching
Naruto is to be entertained, this run delivers.
The final movie of the original Naruto series,
Crescent Moon Kingdom is most notable for
replacing Sasuke with Rock Lee and showing off
the team's new warm-weather outfits. Guardians of
the Crescent Moon Kingdom is placed after Episode
196 because it was released around the same time
as that episode. Plus, scenes from the movie made
it into the opening of Episodes 197 through 199.
But again, both Naruto movies,
Guardians of the Crescent Moon
Kingdom and Legend of the Stone of Gelel,
could theoretically be thrown anywhere,
as long as they end up among the many
filler episodes that finish the series.
Naruto ends with yet more filler episodes.These
episodes are usually a flashback to backstory,
a mission with people from different teams
thrown together to hone their skills,
a display of strengthening alliances, or an
exploration of a "What if?" scenario. Episode 220,
in which Naruto leaves with the legendary sannin
Jiraiya, is tied to the same event in the comics,
and is therefore canon. If you're looking to
speed through the series, jump to this episode.
Naruto: Shippuden opens from the point of view
of an unseen person, running down mysterious
corridors. We've jumped almost three years into
the future, from the end of the first series.
It's a bit confusing, but from the moment "Hero's
Come Back!!" by Japanese hip-hop group Nobodyknows
starts to play over the series' first opening
sequence, it's impossible not to get excited.
The series opens with a bang, as the Akatsuki
attack Hidden Sand Village, capturing Gaara,
decimating the Sand forces, and almost killing
Kankuro. Naruto is more mature, Sakura is
significantly stronger, and all their young
friends have aged up into formidable shinobi.
Plus, Naruto has upgraded his blue and orange
outfit to a sleek black and orange look.
Unfortunately, the Naruto: Shippuden movies can
be even tougher to fit into the right order than
the original Naruto flicks. Not only are there
simply more episodes and arcs to sort through,
some of these movies have serious
inconsistencies with the canon story.
That said, this one is relatively easy to fit.
Naruto Shippuden the Movie premiered during the
Kazekage Rescue arc, which ends at Episode 32. In
this movie, we see a team made up of Naruto,
Sakura, Rock Lee, and Neji. Neji is the only
person from their class who's reached the elite
status of jonin. Like many other Naruto movies,
grand salvation occurs in this one, thanks
to a special version of Naruto's Rasengan.
In these episodes, Team Seven is reformed
with Sai, an untrustworthy but powerful
ninja from the mysterious Foundation, who becomes
Sasuke's permanent replacement. Captain Yamato,
a former Anbu black ops ninja, is brought in to
head the team in place of an injured Kakashi.
In this run, we see more of the Akatsuki's
plans, more about Danzo's techniques,
and even a reunion between Naruto
and the now frighteningly powerful
Sasuke — the scene depicted in
the opening to this new series.
The most notable elements of Naruto Shippuden the
Movie: Bonds are its airships, a very advanced
technology, and a Zero-Tails — neither of which
are ever mentioned before or after this movie.
Since episodes 70 and 71 are non-canon,
you can watch this after either of those,
before you return to canon storylines
at 72. What happens in this flick? Well,
Orochimaru is sick and Sasuke is still doing his
bidding, which brings him together with Naruto as
they take on a man who may have a technique that
could help the ailing Orochimaru. This limits the
film to happening before Episode 114, when Sasuke
and Orochimaru's relationship comes to a head.
A lot happens in this stretch of episodes.
Here, we witness the death of a major sensei,
the rise of the new Ino-Shika-Cho team, and Naruto
inventing a new super-powerful jutsu. Though the
second half of this run — from Episode 91 to
Episode 112 — is considered quasi-canon, it does
contain a tailed beast which makes some impact
on the storyline. You should give this a watch.
Will of Fire is one of the few movies
with references to things from the series,
which make it clear that it has to take
place after the Kakashi Chronicles episodes,
which end with Episode 120. Also, Naruto, Sai, and
Sakura break village rules and follow Kakashi, an
act of disobedience Sai would only have been able
to commit after some time spent with Team Seven.
In Will of Fire, shinobi boasting Kekkei Genkai
abilities have been stolen from everywhere but
Hidden Leaf Village, casting suspicion upon the
villagers. When Kakashi is compelled to leave the
village through a mysterious curse implanted
in him, Tsunade allows him to go as an act of
self-sacrifice. But, as previously mentioned, Team
Seven follows, joined by other teams in support.
There is a huge death in this run, one that
hits Naruto especially hard. The Akatsuki also
seriously increase their activity, and
Jiraiya is haunted by a student from his past.
In an especially important flashback, Jiraiya
even offers the viewers a major revelation as
to Naruto's parentage. Sasuke finally gets the
revenge that has motivated him for most of his
life ... and realizes he knew nothing. In the
aftermath, he joins the seriously-dwindled
Akatsuki. This stretch of episodes contains an
arc some fans call filler, which actually ends
up having a big role in later episodes. Bottom
line: These episodes are impactful and important.
"Oh Yeah??"
Naruto Shippuden the Movie: The Lost Tower has
to occur within a very small window of canon.
It happens after the death of a major character,
but before that person's killer launches a tragic
attack. Naruto discovers this heavy death
in Episode 152, helps the village deal with
the investigation in Episode 153 and Episode
154, and is transported to a far-off land for
secluded training in Episode 155. So, this
movie has to happen between 154 and 155.
The Lost Tower features an interesting
Naruto/Yamato time-travel element,
in which our hero comes face-to-face with
the ninja the audience now understands
to be his father. Moreover, the action
scenes and animation are amazing.
A powerful Akastuki member rains devastation on
Hidden Leaf Village while Naruto is off training.
When Naruto returns, we see the troublemaker
whom everybody once despised finally gaining
the admiration, respect, and love of Hidden
Leaf Village. We also learn about the power
of a new ocular jutsu known as the Rinnegan, a
Kekkei Genkai ability a few steps up from the
Byakugan and Sharingan. Meanwhile, the Akatsuki
lose the man we'd long believed to be their
leader. As it turns out, the once-foolish Tobi is
actually much more astute than we'd ever imagined.
"Yay! Naruto!"
Of all the movies in the series, this is the
toughest to place due to inconsistencies. The
Raikage still has both arms,
yet Naruto knows Killer Bee,
neither of which occur at the same time in
the series. Those inconsistencies aside,
the fact that Naruto has mastered Sage Mode and
knows who his father is places this movie after
Pain's attack on Hidden Leaf Village. Plus, it
has to happen before the Five Kage Summit arc,
which starts at Episode 197. So, we're
putting Blood Prison after Episode 196,
with the caveat that this movie is so non-canon
it might be impossible to truly pinpoint.
Blood Prison is also unique in that
Naruto isn't joined by any of his
Hidden Leaf Village friends for the
majority of the film. As a result,
he has to make new allies within the
prison where he's wrongly incarcerated.
Though Road to Ninja: Naruto the Movie is
technically non-canon, it has some relevance,
as it's a depiction of what Tobi's
genjutsu world would really look like.
In Road to Ninja, Naruto and Sakura are
transferred to Tobi's Infinite Tsukuyomi world,
where Naruto's parents are still alive and
Sakura's parents died defending the village.
Naruto already met his mom in Episode 246, so
his ability to identify her in the movie places
it after the end of that arc in Episode 251.
Episode 252 begins the run-up to the Shinobi War,
with Tobi too busy trying to attain Nagato's
Rinnegan to cast the Infinite Tsukuyomi. So,
this movie has to happen between
Episodes 251 and 252.
This massive run of 240 episodes is impossible
to properly describe in a timely fashion. Here
we encounter the Fourth Great Shinobi
War, Naruto and Sasuke's final battle,
and Naruto's ascendancy to a status unimaginable
to anybody who knew the boy growing up.
These episodes feature amazing battle after
amazing battle, creating an absolutely
jaw-dropping storyline that goes toe-to-toe with
the greatest anime sagas around. Though again,
Episode 311 should be watched immediately
after 251, not in its series order.
The Last: Naruto the Movie is the only canon
Naruto movie. It sets in motion so much that
impacts the lives of the characters that it is
absolutely a required watch. This movie takes
place after the Great Shinobi War and Naruto's
showdown with Sasuke, but before the final arc
that takes place from Episode 494 through Episode
500. This movie also jumps forward a couple years,
bringing Naruto into young manhood. So,
between Episodes 493 and 494 it is.
This run of episodes closes out Shippuden. It's
a couple years after the Great Shinobi War,
and there are lots of good feelings going around.
It's been a long journey — 720 episodes and 10
movies long, to be precise — and the troubled,
no-good boy ninja with a demon inside him has
become the greatest shinobi in the land.
These episodes benefit from that fact.
Naruto's story doesn't end there — he and his
wife Hinata have a son named Boruto. As with the
original series, Boruto: Naruto Next Generations
is based on a manga created by Masashi Kishimoto,
which follows a new boy ninja growing up
in the shadow of his father's greatness.
Episodes 1 through 49 chronicle Boruto's
life as he makes his way in the academy,
and his early days on Team Konohamaru.
Though Naruto was a horrible student and
a social pariah in his early days, Boruto's
journey is very different from his father's.
In this movie, Boruto has graduated from the
academy and joined Team Konohamaru with Sarada
and Mitsuki. The story told here is also
explored in the series, so if you prefer,
you can watch Episodes 50 through 65 and check
out the movie after, or skip the movie entirely.
The movie was released before the series, and
is an adaptation of the Boruto manga, making it
canon. Take note: There are some details of the
story that differ between movies and series.
Boruto's path to becoming a great shinobi is
certainly different from his father's, but taking
it in is just as fun and memorable. The show
is still running, and, given the length of the
previous series, that might remain the case for a
very long time. For however long this saga remains
ongoing, devoted fans will flock to it, eager to
enjoy the adventures of these powerful fighters.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Nartuo are
coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.